and it's just been confirmed that the
champions league final
in may will be moved from some
petersburg and held instead in paris
following
what is happening here jackie beltrau is
joining me now so jackie we were just
waiting to hear where it was going to be
and it is going to be in paris
yeah actually weren't even expecting to
know where it was going to be today but
they have moved very quickly uh the uefa
executive committee it was an emergency
meeting that started at nine o'clock
this morning and they have announced
that it's going to move to paris we
imagine uh the stad de france which has
got an 81 000 or just over capacity um
moving that showcase final the champions
league final which was due to be played
in st petersburg at the gas prom arena
and ua for coming under all sorts of
pressure now to uh distance themselves
from gazprom one of their main sponsors
they give them 33 million pounds per
season a huge sponsor of european
football what will they do now will they
walk away from that uh big questions for
fifa today as well regarding russia and
the world cup and the world cup playoffs
they're still in them they're due to
play poland in moscow at the end of
march poland do not want to play that
match in russia sweden and the czech
republic are in their group they do not
want to play any of the matches in
russia and fifa have a letter from those
three countries saying what are you
going to do we don't want to play those
matches in russia so fifa thinking on
that right now wondering what is going
to be their next move also this affects
scotland as well they are due to play
the ukraine in their playoff match that
is in scotland but ukraine football is
in lockdown at the moment it's been
suspended as of yesterday as you'd
imagine so will that match go ahead that
seems to be under threat as well and it
sort of begs the question as well you
know we're about to start the
paralympics
what is going to happen to the russian
olympic committee team
they obviously ended the winter olympics
in disgrace because of the whole valley
eva drugs debacle
as of now that team is still allowed to
compete and it does make you wonder
what else russia needs to do to get
kicked out of the olympic movement but
as of now they are still allowed to
compete even though they have broken the
olympic truce with this invasion